ja gut und beginne ich noch einmal liebe
österreicherinnen und österreicher liebe
mitbürgerinnen und mitbürger
meine damen und herren zu hause die
bilder die uns seit gestern erreichen
zeigen ein verstörendes sittenbild ein
sittenbild das unserem land und seinen
menschen nicht gerecht wird
es sind beschämende bilder und niemand
soll sich für österreich schämen müssen
ich möchte in aller deutlichkeit sagen
so sind wir nicht so ist österreich
einfach nicht was diese sittenbild aber
auch zeigt dass familiäre in aller
klarheit ist eine dreiste
respektlosigkeit den bürgerinnen und
bürgern unseres landes gegenüber
verantwortungsträger der republik haben
das in sie gesetzte vertrauen gebrochen
das ist eine unerhörte respektlosigkeit
bürgerinnen und bürgern gegenüber
und diese respektlosigkeit toleriere ich
nicht die österreichische bevölkerung
muss sich auch die integrität der
regierung auf die integrität der
verantwortungsträger und auch die
integrität der institutionen verlassen
können und wir alle müssen unseren
institutionen vertrauen können
das ist das fundament unserer demokratie
wenn dieses vertrauen der hat
grundsätzlich erschüttert ist wie es
derzeit der fall ist dann steht die
handlungsfähigkeit einer regierung
infrage
das ist jetzt der fall ja die situation
ist unübersichtlich
aber gerade in dieser situation sehe ich
es als meine verantwortung an dafür zu
sorgen dass unser land mit ruhe und
stabilität durch die nächsten tage und
wochen geführt wird
mein blick gilt allein dem wohle
österreichs symbole aller menschen die
in unserer schönen
leben in diesem sinne habe ich mit
bundeskanzler kurz vorgezogene wahlen in
österreich besprochen und werde morgen
in einem weiteren treffen die nächsten
schritte mit ihm vereinbaren
jetzt muss getan werden was notwendig
ist um das vertrauen wiederherzustellen
die heutigen rücktritte waren ein erster
schritt es darf aber kein zweifel zurück
bleiben das nicht einzig das wohlergehen
unseres landes im zentrum aller
politischen bemühungen der
verantwortungsträger steht meine damen
und herren es bedarf einer klaren
schonungslosen vollständigen aufklärung
aufklärung durch unsere exekutive und
unsere justiz und auf die an dieser
stelle möchte ich auch auf die
wesentliche rolle auch die zentrale
rolle hinweisen die unabhängiger
journalismus in einer liberalen
demokratie spielt die sogenannte vierte
macht hat in diesem fall ihre
verantwortung voll wahrgenommen
die vorrangige aufgabe ist nun das
vertrauen in unsere institutionen wieder
herzustellen nach innen wie nach außen
die österreicherinnen und österreicher
haben ein recht auf eine regierung der
sie vertrauen können
eine regierung die in österreich in
europa der ganzen welt ansehen und
respekt hin ist meine damen und herren
wem immer von den wählerinnen und
wählern das vertrauen geschenkt wird hat
sein amt in demut auszuüben
wir brauchen in diesem sinne einen
neuaufbau des vertrauens dieser
neuaufbau glied in diesem fall nur mit
neuwahlen und ich verspreche ihnen dass
ich diesen neuaufbau mit bett nach
besten wissen und gewissen vorantreiben
und begleiten werde
ich danke ihnen für ihre wertvolle zeit
und wünsche ihnen noch ein
schönen abend dankeschön
[Musik]
sobald die mutter satt ist kann sie